l'équipe fait savoir est ce la religion
chroniqueurs qui a trouvé l'amour sur le
plateau de thé pembe attention hein je
vous la vérité rien que la vérité est ce
qu a déjà un chroniqueur qui a trouvé
l'amour
d'abord on le sait le plateau de tpm
paix l'amour et le sexe l'amour le sexe
attention vous avez un capteur donc je
vous le dis on saura si vous mentez ou
pas tiens d'art matthieu delormeau vous
êtes en train de dire vous vous avez
déjà il a dit l'amour ou laisser du sexe
avec une personne à faire une raymond
beast jeune et j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
tarifie la question mario ou sexe amour
amour est à sec plus extrême attention
on saura si on bouge appartement qui
avait ressurgi alors attention équipe
bernard montiel il faut appuyer mais
j'appuie je sais que ça ne marche pas
merci attention avec les doigts je vous
le dis déjà publiques et les capteurs
s'accélère pour certains isabelle ses
plats donc je sais que ce n'est pas
benjamin mettez votre mort ce qui ne
marche pas benjamin quelque chose à nous
dire qui à moi rien du tout il ya du
toit je vous le dis les doigts n'est pas
castaldi montiel ça n'est pas vous non
plus moi ça marche quand gérald et non
plus ah ok j'enlève ma main alors
vraiment marche pas est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à nous dire ce que vous
avez déjà eu un crush sur le plateau non
vraiment bas raymond banon
ok j'adore valérie vraiment ça
s'accélère et matam allé les voir et
m'ont presse et vers 9h 9h30 non mais
regarde je vous dis non
vous êtes sur certaines oui et d'aurélie
droit dans les yeux
a vous d d'ophélie holla holla sage en a
la garde en stock mais novelli jean
michel maire
si vous avez déjà eu un crush sur le
plateau de 5 c'est pas pratique lequel
pato n'a changé souvent le plateau celui
là celui ci l'a ouais donc ça paye
depuis trois ans oui jean michel aulas
ou non ne s'est pas concrétisé non c'est
peut-être pas vous en dire plus sur ce
compte jean-michel pour qui tu es là ma
chérie qu'il a un cyril à l'autre qu'il
ya eu un crush sur ce plateau est bien
celui qui ment et de vous défouler après
à la boîte à gâteaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
j'en ai
ce matin
[Musique]
nous sommes en direct
jean michel merle et la citram le 30
jean michel maire
est-ce que vous lui avez parlé au nom
d'un premier que n'ont pas non je posais
franchement vialelle le plateau tient là
le pathos et que cette jeune fille aime
l'émission c'est la démission à même les
chroniques si elle aime les chroniqueurs
elle vous aime pas être même quoi elle
vous aime peut-être à une chose là si
elle regarde les yeux regarde jean
michel est ce que vous avez vraiment eu
un croche
j'ai eu un bruit j'ai trouvé très très
jolie charmante main distinguez vous
étiez même tétanisés à l'idée d'aller la
voir
maintenant oui je trouve que ça se
faisait pas je suis beaucoup plus vieux
qu'elle enfin je sais pas quel âge elle
a enfin sauf s'il est d'accord
évidemment mais jean-michel suédois
garde ce soir je vous vouliez du pari
sur cette caméra ça nous regarde
sûrement ne sait même pas son prénom sur
la bcl nous regarder qu'elle m'aime bien
on peut toujours discuter
ouais j'aime ont un statut qui ouvre une
phase rocquemont adopteunmec deux teams
glachant version vous tapez l'adresse
dos et on trouve pas c'est vraiment
qu'on ne cherche pas et ces mêmes et
envoyer un message pour aller boire un
verre ça sera un grand plaisir
c'est bien pour qu'il présente à ses
parents évidemment ces messages alors je
ne sais pas si c'est ça je vais toucher
la jeune femme mais en tout cas j'ai une
bonne nouvelle à jo me j'ai enquêté et
je les retrouvais en photo bien sûr en
photo un parole est-ce que c'est elle
c'est bien mais l'un selon me jean
michel ah ba oui c'était là une bouffée
je reconnais au tatouage
elle s'appelle s'appelle comment est là
pour un voile s'appelle maeva et c'est
vrai qu'elle est très très très joli
tout à fait votre style deux femmes
seins alors mais en tout cas je michel
vous êtes au courant qu'un petit écart
d'âge on trouve d'ailleurs je le dis je
le dis
je recherchais pas parler éveillé trotel
d'années de rigueur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ambitionne est ce que vous pourriez
avoir une histoire avec elle parce que
vous êtes déjà sorti fuite de fille de
28 ans 30 ans 35 grands noms mais c'est
bien sur ce que vous pourriez avoir une
histoire et qu'elle comme ça va c'est
pas un problème et je considère très
bien bien sûr athènes personnes sans
soins et bien sûr moi non parce que je
poussais dans la tête tout ça et j'ai
une vie franchement plus plus festif que
des jeunes de 30 ans voilà donc mais on
veut montrer mais qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de la rencontrer
ali ben abi chaîne voulait que
j'organise un rendez vous ouais ce soir
non pas ce soir
ben oui bien sûr oui j'aimerais bien eh
ben j'ai changé d'avis je vais organiser
ce rendez vous ce soir naïve
[Applaudissements]
merci merci maïva alors ce que je vous
propose c'est vraiment bien sûr gare
nettoie ma place tu vas prendre le
capteur de raymond maiva tu vas mettre
ta main vous allez mettre votre main
donc sur l'écran est ce qu'on pourra
mettre en place le capteur ça va mal il
va ça va et vous pas trop stressé non ça
va merci d'être là en tout cas si vous
regardez toujours l'émission souvent
pourquoi vous êtes venu dans le public à
la base j'ai accompagné un ami
adacore a donc pas vous n'étiez pas venu
pour jean michel alabau non non pas la
base à la première maeva je vous posais
des questions dites moi vraiment toute
la vérité maeva maeva jean-michel il est
comme en foot on est un peu gêné pour
elle la pauvre en face et les mêmes
spéciales et elle est très pratique mais
ils auront bien sûr et merci d'être là
mais je vous en prie c'est un amour
maïva lors de votre venue sur le plateau
est ce que vous aviez remarqué le petit
jeu de jean michel maire non non on va
tous non pas du toit mais discret caché
risque comme quoi ils et voilà est ce
que jean-michel fait partie de vos
chroniqueurs préférés puisque vous
connaissez les missions non et qu'est ce
qu'il veut j'aime beaucoup de matchs
isabelle mathieu et sa famille va
envoyer c'est maeva a donc les écarts
d'âge dans un couple pour vous c'est
quoi le plus important qu'est ce que
vous recherchez un homme la fidélité car
j'ai vite et j'ai continué avec
quelqu'un il est très fier mais
franchement bye bye est très fine vous
habite à paris
oui en fait on fait quoi dans la vie
je travaille au tribunal je suis très
fier ah oui votre plat préféré c'est le
risotto à la truffe dans votre signe
astrologique tôt votre musique préférée
j'irai où tu iras céline dion vos
vacances de rêve
les maldives vont creed le critère d'un
mec grand est intelligent et de le
mettre à l'épreuve le pire défaut radin
il n'est pas rare
à l'écran il est intelligent et généreux
il est fils a oublié du coup les petites
questions à vous poser la question il a
tous envie de vous poser
maeva et dites nous la vérité etes-vous
célibataire oui vous êtes célibataire
depuis quand depuis qu'en comptant
longtemps ah ouais vous avez envie de te
trouver l'amour comme tout le monde
comme tout le monde comme tout le monde
exactement maeva ma question il va être
simple et vite
est ce que vous pourriez donner sa
chance à jean michel maire ou pas du
tout prenez votre temps si vous lui
donner sa chance à vous accepter d'aller
boire un verre tout de suite avec
jean-michel tout d'accord moi mon garage
d'accord allez boire un verre
tranquillement
vous apprenez à vous connaître peut-être
une baisse à venir de très bons amis
exact mais attention
mais il va si bien sûr vous allez voir
avec lui dit voilà c'est que c'est par
complètement fermé oui si ces morts ça
ne sera qu'un ami bien sûr il ira
prendre avec vous mais pas ce soir
et bien sûr ce soir c'est pour faire
connaissance mais est-ce que vous pensez
que jean michel maire pourrait être
votre style ce qui pourrait faire partie
de vos critères est ce qu'on peut le
vendre
oui oui c'est bien moi je voulais te
prévenir que jean-michel c'est un des
meilleurs de cette équipe il est
généreux il attentionné il est hyper
gentil il est vrai il est honnête ou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après ça
alors attendez attention je voulais
c'est encore 10 secondes pour répondre
les consommations serait pour moi
évidemment titre et diana il va vous
pouvez dire la canebière la vérité juge
jean-michel est ce que maintenant que
vous avez vu ma y va est ce que vous
êtes encore plus enclins à aller plus
loin avec un pas de plus en plus tout le
monde la trouverez magnifique oui ton
examen avec roche
je suis content pour elle qu'on ait mis
un peu la lumière sur elle ce soir puis
parce qu'elle fait si tu as l'intention
- le quart mannequin n'importe quoi je
suis sûr qu'on va t'appeler les
greffiers à pierre amer bras les
greffières pas ça elle a d'autres
ambitions allez je croyais pas au début
je croyais qu'il était très fier je dis
que ce calme a gravi mondiale et
greffiers elle est très fière
[Rires]
maeva est ce que oui ou non vous
pourriez laisser une chance à jean
michel si on me dit non vous dit non et
on comprendra oui c'est pas la première
fois c'est pas la dernière fois alors
qu'à l'habitude mais il va
la france vous attend à voir l homme
très belle la france mais le gars très
belle hop c'est vrai ça valait l'avez
remarqué je pourrais bien sûr que ça va
leur sang à jeun pour la santé on a mal
à petit indice rien du tout alors là je
vous le dis ne vous fais pas ça non mais
une fille jeanne née je sais que j'ai
amené son âge c'est toi et qu'il est
pour un peu puisque tournage on s'est
rapprochés un peu après l'arrêté maï-maï
très fier ayvaz je te laisse répondent
machel oui oui en tout bien tout honneur
oui je peux me dit j'ai ma réponse quand
même donc tu dis que c'est pas oui c'est
mon nom c'est pas non donc c'est pas nos
adhérents est-ce que la différence d'âge
de tout je sois green
oui non non ça va donc c'est pas c'est
pas éliminatoire et je progresse
franchement je crois que c'était parce
que je vois pas ce qui peut bloquer à
part ça c'est aussi les plus âgés que
son père
tu vois toi tes petites fleurs cassés
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci à vous a vu comme il est
sympathique et merci à fabien drago j
marrant il est alors maggiori donc c'est
plutôt vie oui c'est plutôt oui c'est
plutôt oui oui
[Applaudissements]
pas tout de suite lors pas franchement
alors bon il est resté jusque ce
processus
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire d'un mec mais voulez je
vous dis j'y crois et aussi j'y crois
parce que ma seule petite crainte
c'était la différence d'âge et là j'ai
un petit maïva et voilà elle connaît là
alors viens d'apprendre à le connaître
elle n'est pas complètement close il à
faire déjà non non non je vous le dis
alors eddy maillet bachand très honnête
elle l'aurait dit elle est très fière
maintenant que joueur bavarois